bonjour ici c'est steve kaufmann je vais
vous parler aujourd'hui de
l'apprentissage de la grammaire comment
on apprend les règles de grammaire de
mon avis et si vous aimez vidéo veuillez
s'il vous plaît vous abonner subscribe
sais pas comment vous dites ça français
bon moi j'apprends maintenant j'apprends
le grec et le grec pour moi ce serait ma
17e langues et j'apprends le grec
surtout en écoutant et en lisant
beaucoup mais en lisant des petites
histoires des contes où il ya beaucoup
de répétitions qui ne sont pas très
difficiles et où on utilise surtout les
verts balech plus comment les plus
fréquemment utilisés de la langue et
comme ça je m'habitue à la langue
j'obtiens dix ans une expérience avec la
langue dit maintenant avec des centaines
et des centaines d'heures d'écouté de
lecture je commence à m'intéresser un
peu plus un peu davantage à la grammaire
donc j'ai un petit bouquin de grammaire
et que je lis et je lis et maintenant
puisque j'ai tellement d'expérience avec
la langue
je comprends plus ou moins les
explications parce que ça se réfère à
des choses des phénomènes que j'ai pu
observer dans la langue pendant un
toutou l'écouté la lecture que j'ai fait
et pour moi c'est ça que c'est comme ça
qu'on apprend la grammaire parce que il
ya même un proverbe c'est du suffit
tisme c'est un peu de philosophie
musulmane qui dit on ne peut on ne peut
apprendre que ce qu'on sait déjà
donc si on a déjà de l'expérience avec
la langue les explique
explications de grammaire font du sens
et on a la possibilité de les retenir
et puis de pouvoir les utiliser dans sa
lecture des puits quand on parle en ces
procès d'ailleurs je suis toujours en
faveur de livres de grammaire ou il ya
des explications et des exemples mais
pas d'exercice je ne fais pas des
exercices de grammaire
je trouve ça en mieux et je ne trouve
pas que ça m'aide
mais j'achète des livres de grammaire
qui sont aussi minces que possible voilà
pour l'italien et pour le français est
vrai mais pour le tchèque que j'ai
acheté quand j'étais à prague mais c'est
comme ça que j'utilise cet ebook 1 c'est
comme un livre de référence après que
j'ai déjà
j'ai obtenu suffisamment d'expérience
avec la langue c'est pourquoi c'est
pourquoi pourquoi je ne suis pas un
grand amateur de da 6000 bien que j'en
ai j'aurai quatre essais parce que
assimile confond un peu et il ya du
contenu dans qu'on peut écouter lire il
ya des exercices il ya des explications
de grammaire et pitou convenu je préfère
un petit bouquin de grammaire avec des
explications sans exercice et des
contenus des choses qu'on peut lire
écouter mais avec beaucoup beaucoup de
répétitions
malheureusement avec assimilent sa
progresse à trop vite il n'y a pas assez
de répétition et puis ça devient de plus
en plus difficile moi je préfère au
début et c'est comme ce que j'ai fait
avec le grec
on a cette histoire de sétif compte avec
beaucoup de répétitions que j'écoute et
dans chaque histoire est à trois
sections donc l'histoire
et puis ensuite l'histoire racontée de
d'un point de vue donc je ensuite lui
enfin ensuite des questions et toujours
on reprend les mêmes termes
et puis les mêmes formes
grammaticales et ça ça me permet de
commande directe de 2,2 me former une
idée de comment fonctionne la langue
avant je me lance dans des choses plus
difficiles bon ca combiné combiné avec
donc un petit livre de grammaire
pour moi c'est la façon qu'on apprend la
grammaire on s'expose à la langue on
prend de l'expérience avec la langue et
par la suite on va chercher les
explications pour des phénomènes qu'on a
déjà su et et bien voilà c'est comme ça
que je fais ah oui j'allais ajouter que
bon moi ça maintient ils ont lâché des
livres de grammaire même pour des
langues où je n'en ai pas besoin
mais pour l'heure mais quand je lis les
explications de grammaire pour la langue
anglaise puisque je connais la langue
anglaise bien mieux que n'importe quelle
autre langue
je trouve que tout les expliquer
explications sont superflus et pas
nécessaire
c'est les explications de phénomène que
je connais tellement bien d'une façon
expérimentale pour ainsi dire que gêné
je n'ai pas besoin d'explication c'est
ce serait comme une explication pour
dire vous allez vous mouiller si vous
êtes vous sentez dans l'impuissance
s'empara prix pas besoin donc mieux on
connaît la langue - on a besoin
d'explications de grammaire sauf que
peut-être c'est quand il ya des points
particuliers lac
on a une idée un peu flou voilà on va
aller on peut même aller chercher ça
avec google voilà c'est ce que je
voulais dire en français résumé un peu
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure en
anglais et félicitations en français
pour la participation au processus
démocratique avec un taux de
participation participation bien plus
élevé avec aux états unis par exemple
est même plus élevée qu'au canada
merci au revoir
[Musique]